dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui on va
essayer de démontrer l'équation
d'einstein dans le vide en relativité
générale c'est-à-dire l'équation qui
fixe des restrictions sur la géométrie
de l'espace temps en postulant que cet
espace temps évident et ne contient
aucune matière où aucune énergie pour
faire cette démonstration on va partir
d'un postulat le postulat de l'action
qui est écrit par einstein comme étant s
égal l'intégrale de r v
alors on va voir ce que ce postulat veut
dire et on va essayer d'en déduire
l'équation d'einstein
un principe fondateur en physique c'est
ce qu'on appelle le principe de moindre
action c'est l'idée que l'univers tente
de minimiser une certaine grandeur qu'on
appelle l'action et qu'on note
généralement s est ainsi que pour
déduire des lois physiques on peut
simplement partir de l'action est tenté
de minimiser cette grandeur le postulat
d'einstein c'est de dire que l'action la
grandeur que l'univers tente de
minimiser dans le cadre de la relativité
générale c'est simplement l'intégrale
surtout l'espace temps donc si on
appelle l'espace temps m on peut noter
l'intégrale sur
m2r une grandeur qu'on appelle la
courbure scalaires c'est à dire en fait
une sorte de courbure moyenne de tout
l'univers la courbure de lui tout
l'espace temps intégré par rapport à une
certaine forme volume v qui veut dire
simplement qu'on intègre par rapport au
volume de l'univers et s'il faut faire
attention c'est un volume en quatre
dimensions on parle de la courbure de
l'espace et du temps et donc v est une
forme quadri dimensionnelle
alors pour commencer ce calcul on va
d'abord posé quelques définitions r la
courbure scalaires est défini comme
étant la contraction du tenseur de
richie on utilisera la notation
d'einstein ici est remué avec deux
indices en haut et en bas ça signifie
simplement qu on fait la somme des airs
mue pour mu allant de 0 à 3 c'est à dire
pour toutes les coordonnées en prenant
le temps et les trois coordonnées
l'espace
et ce temps soeur de richie est lui même
défini comme étant est remué donc cette
fois ci en fait pour c'est d'ici à là on
a dû monter un des deux indices pour
faire ça on a eu tout simplement
utiliser la métrique de cette façon donc
en contractant la métrique avec le
danseur de richie on peut monter un des
deux indices et obtenir la trace c'est à
dire la courbure scalaires et ce danseur
de richie ici est défini comme étant lui
même une contraction du tenseur de
riemann
et le temps soeur de riemann est lui
même défini comme étant des dérives et
des symboles de christophe elle
donc ici les dérivés sont notés comme ça
avec des des ronds
plus des contractions de symboles de
christophe elle
voilà donc là on a des expressions qui
peut faire un peu peur mais c'est
uniquement des définitions qui viennent
de la géométrie différentielle ou plutôt
de la géométrie rayman yens et on va
simplement les accepter et les utiliser
dans notre démonstration
d'autre part la forme volume v ici c'est
simplement la forme par rapport à
laquelle on intègre c'est le volume d'un
tout petit cube ou plutôt d'un tueur de
parler logram à quatre dimensions
qui est définie par rapport à nos
coordonnées donc on a nos coordonnées x
y z par exemple et puis le temps qui
serait une quatrième coordonnées donc on
a une sorte de parallélogramme à quatre
dimensions avec des longueurs
infinitésimale des côtés de taille est
infinitésimal et ce venous donne en
quelque sorte une forme différentiel qui
représente le volume de ce petit cube
infinitésimale donc en particulier cette
forme volume c'est simplement le produit
d intervalle ici des coordonnées donc on
pourrait noter d'été dx des grecs des
aides pour les quatre coordonnées mais
on va plus simplement écrire des 4 x
pour indiquer qu'on intègre sur quatre
dimensions et à cela il faut rajouter un
produit qui est la racine carrée de
moins le déterminant de la métrique et
ça pourquoi simplement parce que là nos
coordonnées sont des sondés nombre
abstrait en fait on pourrait avoir des
coordonnées qui sont complètement
déformée et donc notre volume ne
représenteraient pas
réellement un volume physique et la
métrique a justement pour but de nous
indiquer quel est le volume de ce petit
parallélogramme infinitésimale en tout
cas le déterminant des métriques nous
dit ça quand on en prend la racine
carrée il faut mettre un signe - ici
puisqu'on intègre un volume spatio
temporelle et dans l'espace temps le
temps à une signature négative par
rapport à l'espace c'est la propriété un
peu spéciale du temps et donc là aussi
c'est une sorte de définition il faut
savoir que pour intégrer pour faire une
intégrale dans l'espace temps on va
toujours intégré de cette façon là
donc maintenant qu'on a ces définitions
on va pouvoir commencer le calcul et le
calcul se base sur d'un principe qui est
le principe variations l on va faire
varier l'action en faisant varier très
légèrement la géométrie donc la métrique
de l'espace temps on va imaginer qu'on
est con à trouver quelle est la
géométrie parfaite la géométrie optimale
de l'espace temps pour minimiser
l'action eon va imaginer qu'on l'a des
formes très légèrement qu'on fait varier
la métrique un tout petit peu et on
regarde quelle est la variation de
l'action lorsqu'on fait cette variation
de metric et l'idée c'est que la
variation de l'action si on se trouve
effectivement au niveau d'un minimum
d'actions donc on imagine que l'action
c'est une sorte de fonction comme ça si
on se trouve effectivement au minimum un
minimum local et bien en variant un tout
petit peu comme ça
la variation d'action doit être nul
c'est à dire que lapentti 6 doit valoir
0 et donc ce qu'on veut trouver cds
delta est égal zéro ou delta sc la
variation de l'action lorsqu'on fait
varier la métrique et donc en
particulier on va faire varier j'ai mis
nu alors ici on va faire varier linverse
de la métrique car ça rend les calculs
plus simple et puis au niveau du du
tenseur énergie impulsion les
conventions sont de définir le temps sur
nrj impulsion par rapport à la variation
de l'un vers ce de la métrique mais bon
c'est simplement un choix de convention
alors c'est parti commence on le calcule
donc on va réécrire un peu tout ça on à
l'action qui est égal à l'intégrale de r
la courbure scalaires fois la racine de
- g le déterminant de la métrique des 4
x et l'idée ça va être de faire varier
tout ça donc lorsqu'on fait varier
l'action ici on a la variation de
l'action on doit aussi faire varier
l'autre côté de l'équation est donc la
variation de l'action est égal à
l'intégrale de la variation de tout ça
alors la variation tout ça c'est la
variation de r racine de manger des 4 x
et la variation d'un produit c'est un
peu comme les dérivés lorsqu'on à la
dérive et d'un produit
c'est le produit de supprimer plus eu
des primes bien là ça va être la même
chose lorsqu'on à la variation de huget
on a la variation de bus x v plus une
fois la variation de v
est donc ici la variation de m racine de
manger c'est simplement la variation de
r x racines de manger plus r fois la
variation de racines de manger le tout
intégré sur des 4 x est donc ici on voit
qu'on a deux termes à déterminer on va
les faire un par un on a d'abord ce
premier terme qu'on va faire ensuite
qu'on va faire en deuxième et ce
deuxième terme qu'on va faire tout de
suite donc ce deuxième terme on a r fois
la variation de racines de moins le
déterminant de la métrique pour calculer
cette variation on va utiliser une
astuce l'idée c'est que à la fin on va
se retrouver avec une intégrale qui
possède toujours ce racines de moins
géant facteurs pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce qu'on veut se retrouver
avec une intégrale d'un d'une grandeur
fois la forme volume et donc tout ça on
peut le réécrire comme air delta racines
de - g sur racine de manger fois racines
de manger comme ça sera signe de manger
on va pouvoir le sortir et le mettre en
facteur
est donc lorsqu'on fait ça on se
retrouve avec la variation de racine à
manger sur racine de manger et saha vous
reconnaissez peut-être c'est la
variation du logarithme puisque
lorsqu'on fait varier le logarithme de
manger c'est comme lorsqu'on dérive un
logarithme on obtient la dérive et de ce
qui se trouve dans le logarithme / ceux
qui se trouvent dans le logarithme en
est donc là on obtient en fait r x delta
log de racines de manger
et si comme j'ai dit on va faire bien
attention à sortir leurs racines de
manger
on le met en facteur
ici voilà on avait divisé par racine à
manger et du coup le racine de manger
revient en facteur ici
alors là on va pouvoir simplifier un peu
tout ça on voit qu'on a la variation du
logarithme d'une racine carrée or le
logarithme d'une racine carrée c'est un
demi fois le logarithme de ce qui se
trouve dans la racine donc on peut
écrire un demi de r en sortant le 1/2 de
delta lloyd 2 - j'ai donc on a d'une
certaine façon le logarithme du
déterminant de notre métriques alors pas
exactement mais vu qu'on a un signe -
mais le signe - on peut imaginer prendre
là la matrice qui représente notre
métriques donc on va l'a noté avec un
team ici pour parler vraiment de la
matrice de la métrique et multiplier
cette matrice par le hippie sur quatre
c'est à dire une racine 4e 2 - 1 et
lorsqu'on prend le déterminant de tout
ça on obtient bien - g c'est à dire - le
déterminant de g puisque ce - ceipi sur
quatre à la puissance 4 donc en passant
de cette façon par les nombres complexes
on peut se retrouver simplement avec le
logarithme d'une matrice
cette matrice et en a donc on va
l'appeler à la matrice est en eux et
hippie sur quatre fois la matrice de la
métrique voilà noté atild
est donc ici ce delta log du coup de
ac1 logarithme d'un déterminant donc de
dette à
est une propriété des matrices diagonale
is able c'est que le logarithme du
déterminant d'une matrice est égale à la
trace de logarithmes et cette fois ci
c'est un logarithme matricielle de la
matrice alors ça veut dire quoi le gars
rythme matricielle et bien c'est trouver
une matrice b tel que
exponentielle de bep au sens des
matrices égalera
est donc ici on va faire la trace de
cette matrice b tel que exponentielle de
beghal a
donc on peut remplacer tout ça ça fait
un demi de r x delta et du coup locke
dette devient traces log donc traces du
log de à
la propriété ici intéressante c'est que
la trace est linéaire et donc on peut la
sortir du delta et donc ça ça fait un
demi de air de la trace de delta log de
la matrice à
est ici lorsqu'on prend le delta du log
de la matrice à à l'intérieur d'une
trace une propriété c'est que c'est
comme ici c'est comme pour les nombres
le delta du log d'une matrice à
l'intérieur d'une trace c'est le delta
de la matrice divisée c'est à dire fois
l' inverse de la matrice donc en
particulier c'est l' inverse de la
matrice fois le delta de la matrice
alors ici j'écris égales par abus de
langage c'est uniquement à l'intérieur
de la trace que ces deux valeurs peuvent
être égaliser
et donc tout ça ici ça va nous donner
simplement un délit de r
fois la trace
de à -1 delta a
est alors ici quelque chose qui est très
intéressant c'est que ce e hippie sur
quatre wass annulé puisque ici on le
retrouve une fois et si on leur trouve
inversé et donc dans le produit ici les
2e et hippie sur 4 cellules donc on peut
remplacer directement à part la métrique
donc ici on a la trace de l' inverse de
la métrique x la variation de la
métrique ou en termes matricielle
donc pour finir si on écrit cette trace
en notation d'einstein on obtient un
demi de r fois l' inverse de la métrique
cg menu avec les indices en os x delta
de génie nul et si on contracte bien vu
comprend la trace une toute dernière
étape j'ai dit que par convention on
allait prendre on allait s'intéresser
aux variations de la métrique inverse
donc avec les indices en eau donc ce
qu'on peut faire ici c'est considérer le
fait que la maîtrise lorsqu'on la
contracte avec elle même ceci vaut
simplement delta mumu c'est à dire 4 vu
qu'on est en 4 dimensions donc ici c'est
un symbole de chroniqueurs c'est le
temps soeur trivial et donc si on
différencie tout ça si on prend la
variation de tout ça on obtient la
variation d'un pro lui donc delta gmi
lui j'ai mis nu plus j'ai mis nu delta g
menu égal la variation d'un nombre
constant c zéro et donc on a cette
égalité que delta j'ai mis nu avec les
indices en bas fois j'ai mis nu avec les
indices quant aux est égal à - en
passant ça de l'autre côté - j'ai mis nu
avec les indices en bas cette fois-ci et
delta gmi nul avec les indices ont donc
en fait ici on peut simplement passer
les indices en bas
et en haut ici dans la variation à
condition de rajouter un signe - et là
on a finalement obtenu la valeur de ce
premier terme en fonction de ce qui nous
intéresse c'est à dire la variation de
la métrique
maintenant on va passer au calcul du
deuxième terme ce delta air alors pour
calculer delta air on va se rappeler de
la formule qui définit r la courbure
scalaires et en particulier c'est cette
formule là qui nous intéresse donc delta
air
ça va être le delta de gemin x est remué
alors ici on a encore une fois le delta
la variation d'un produit et donc on
peut décomposer ça comme étant la somme
de delta j'ai mis nu fois est revenu
plus j'ai mis nu fois delta ii et remue
alors ici ce premier terme il est très
bien puisqu'on a directement la
variation de la métrique telle qu'on
utilise dans nos conventions donc ça
c'est parfait par contre ce 2e terme ici
est différent et donc on va essayer de
le calculer alors je vais mettre une
autre couleur pour que ce soit plus
clair et on va s'intéresser à ce terme
aussi en particulier et en fait on va
voir que ce terme disparaît il ne
contribue pas et pourquoi ils ne
contribuent pas c'est parce qu'on peut
le mettre sous la forme d'une divergence
et l'intégrale d'une divergence dans
l'espace temps en considérant que
l'espace temps n'a pas de bord par le
théorème de la divergence vaut zéro donc
notre but ici ça va être de démontrer
que cette grandeur peut être exprimé
comme la divergence de l'incertain en
tenseur alors commençons par calculer ce
delta air menu est revenu on a vu que
c'était le temps soeur de richie qui se
calcule à partir du tenseur de riemann
qui se calculent lui même à partir des
symboles de christophe elle donc pour
commencer une première idée ce serait de
calculer les variations d'un symbole de
christophe elle donc prenons un symbole
de christoffel et prenons sa variation
alors les symboles de christophe elles
sont définies de la façon suivante
le symbole de christoffel en romu est
égale 1 demi de l' inverse de la
métrique avec une variable muette ici un
coordonnées muette lambda fois les
dérives et donc d'abord par rapport à mu
de la métrique avec nuland a plus la
dérive et par rapport à nu de la
métrique avec menu lambda - la dérive et
paraboles lambda de la métrique avec mu
ça c'est la définition des symboles de
christophe elle est donc a priori pour
calculer la variation d'un symbole de
christophe elle il faudrait calculer
tout cette variation est si ce qui
serait très long l'on peut utiliser une
astuce qui est le fait que notre
espace-temps est une sorte de grille et
que localement on peut toujours autour
d'un point choisir des coordonnées qui
sont plates c'est à dire qu'ils sont
localement
régulière un peu comme à la surface de
la terre ou localement vous pouvez
définir un plan même si la surface
globale de la terre aesvt eric vous
pouvez toujours localement trouver un
plan qui est en jean à la surface de la
terre et définir une grille de
coordonner cartésienne qu'il est pas
valable sur toute la terre mais qui est
valable localement à proximité du point
donc de la même façon on peut faire ce
choix de coordonner dans l'espace temps
c'est ce qu'on appelle des coordonnées
normale et l'intérêt de ses coordonnées
normal c'est que tous les symboles de
christophe elles valent 0 lorsqu'on
utilise ses coordonnées la tous les
symboles de christophe elles valent 0
pourquoi parce que toutes les dérives et
de la métrique vannes 0 uniquement au
point auquel on se trouve pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont choisi justement précisément
choisi des coordonnées tels que la
métrique et régulière et constante
localement donc dans ce choix de
coordonner encore donné normal la
variation du symbole de christophe elle
va être un peu plus simple
donc ici on a un produit entre cette
grandeur et cette grandeur l'a donc a
priori on devrait prendre la variation
de sa foi tout ça plus la variation de
tout ça fois ça sauf qu'ici on a vu que
tout s'était remis seewald 0 et donc si
on prend la variation de sa foi tout ça
on obtient 0 donc en fait la variation
du symbole de christophe elle va être
uniquement ceux ci fois les variations
de ses dérivés donc on obtient 1 de li
de géo lambda et si la variation d'une
dérive et c'est la dérive et d'une
variation par linéarité donc on a des
murs de delta j'ai nu lambda plus des
nues de delta ge lambda - des landes à
de delta j mu
est ici ce qui va être très pratique
c'est qu'on peut tout de suite remplacé
nos dérivées partielles qui sont des
dérivés dans l'espace abstrait des
coordonnées par des dérivés qu variante
c'est à dire des dérivés tance auriel
des dérivés géométriques pourquoi on
peut faire ça c'est parce que justement
n'utilise des coordonnées normal et donc
que nos symboles de christophe elle qui
décrivent la différence entre les
dérivés selon les coordonnées et les
dérivés selon la géométrie son nul au
point auquel on s'intéresse donc on peut
tout de suite écrire que tout ceci est
égale à la même chose mais en remplaçant
toutes les dérives et par des dérivés qu
variantes
et ça ça va être très pratique puisque
on se retrouve avec un tenseur à droite
on a des dérivés qu variante du danseur
métriques qui est un temps seraient donc
les dérivés qu variante d'intenses
heures sont intenses heures et donc tout
ceci est un tenseur est ce que ça veut
dire c'est que cette équation n'est pas
seulement valable dans le système de
coordonnées normal mais dans tous les
systèmes de coordonner ceci est une
équation qui est valable géométriquement
de cette façon on a obtenu une
expression qui nous donne les variations
des symboles de christophe elle alors
maintenant ce qui nous intéresse c'est
la variation du tenseur de richie et
donc on va remonter une étape plus haut
à partir des symboles de christophe l on
peut exprimer le danseur de riemann et
on va calculer d'abord la variation du
tenseur de riemann alors on utilisant
toujours des coordonnées normal les
symboles de christophe elles sont nulles
leurs dérivés ne sont pas forcément nul
mais les symboles de christoffel en eux
mêmes sont nuls et donc ces deux termes
ici encore donné normal ça nul donc là
dès la définition du tenseur de riemann
est plus simple encore de normal c'est
simplement ces deux termes
alors on va écrire ça tout de suite
le temps soeur de riemann
est égal à dému gamma sygma n'eurent au
moins des nues gamma sygma mureaux
et donc la variation du tenseur de
riemann
est égal à dému fois la variation du
symbole de christophe elle - des nues
fois la variation du symbole de
christophe elle
est ici encore une fois comme on est
encore donnée normal on peut tout de
suite écrire que ses dérivées partielles
sont en réalité égal aux dérivés qu
variantes et on se retrouve une nouvelle
fois avec une équation qui es tu en sors
yale et qui est donc valable dans tous
les systèmes de coordonner
et maintenant ce qui nous intéresse
c'est le temps soeur de richie est
revenu qui est défini comme la
contraction du tenseur de riemann lorsqu
on égalise ces deux indices et donc on
va simplement contracté cette expression
avec les indices sigma ému
et on va renommer lundi sro par mu et on
obtient donc delta ii r mu est égale à
la dérive échos variante donc ici mu on
va le renommé en sigma ii sigma fois la
variation du symbole de christophe elle
en sigma mu - la dérive échos variantes
par rapport à nu de la variation du
symbole de christophel de cette fois-ci
musique m'a
hélas cette expression est très
intéressante pourquoi parce qu'on voit
directement qu'on a des dérivés qu
variantes et donc on se rapproche d'une
divergence lors ce qui nous intéressait
pour finir c'était le produit de gmi lui
avec ce delta air mais dieu donc on va
multiplier tout ça par jemini
et comme ici on a des dérivés qu
variante on peut directement rentré la
métrique j'ai mis nu dans la dérive
échos variante puisque la dérive échos
variante de la métrique en utilisant la
connexion standard de l'éviter vita en
relativité générale vos héros donc tous
à vos simplement la dérive échos
variantes par rapport à sygma de gym
innues fois delta gamma sygma menu
- la dérive échos variantes par rapport
à nu
2g menu foie delta gamma sygma et sigma
ici on a presque terminé toutes les
variables y six sigma menus sont des
variables muette sont des indices muet
et donc on peut les renommer à volonté
et par exemple on va pouvoir nommer ce
nu ici en sigma à condition de renommée
ce site my sea en quelque chose d'autre
donc appelons le nu
et ceci va nous permettre de tout
rentrer dans une même dérivés qu
variantes
donc on à la dérive échos variantes par
rapport à sigma 2 j'ai mis nu delta
gamma sygma menu - geemu sigma delta
gamme à nu
tout ceci est un tenseur puisqu'on a vu
ici que les deltas des gammes à des
symboles de christophe elles étaient des
danseurs du fait que ce sont des dérivés
qu variantes et donc on se retrouve bien
avec ici la dérive échos variante d'un
certain vecteur x sigma qui est défini
comme étant j'ai minul delta gamma sygma
menu - gmi sigma delta gamma du manioc
ceci c'est bien la divergence d'un
vecteur
est donc l'intégrale de tout ceci vaut
zéro
alors le calcul était un peu fastidieux
mais l'idée c'est vraiment que ce terme
ici ne contribue pas et qu'il s'agit
simplement d'une divergence intégré sur
tout l'espace temps qui s'annulent et en
a maintenant terminé de calculer toutes
les parties de l'intégrale on va pouvoir
mettre tout cela en commun donc pour
résumer
la variation de cette intégrale de
l'action alors je vais l'écrire ici la
variation de l'action est égal à
l'intégrale de ce delta air on a vu
qu'il ya uniquement ce terme là qui
contribuent et on va tout de suite
mettre le delta j'ai mis nu en facteur
donc on a simplement est revenu avec un
delta j'ai mis nu en facteurs et puis on
a ce racines de manger des 4 x
et de l'autre côté ce terme ici nous
avait donné 1 - 1/2 de hergé mu et donc
on se retrouve avec hermine lui - 1/2 de
air gemini
est ce si c'est parfois renommée gmi nul
c'est un tenseur très important en
relativité générale c'est ce qu'on
appelle le temps soeur d'einstein
est donc en particulier ce que nous dit
le principe de moindre action c'est que
si on fait varier l'action par rapport à
l' inverse de la métrique gmail si on
veut que ceci va le zéro il faut
forcément sachant que le déterminant de
la métrique n'est jamais nul que cette
grandeur ce temps soeur d'einstein
vannes 0 et donc est remué - 1/2 de
hergé mulet
est égal à zéro
et ceci c'est l'équation finale
l'équation d'einstein de la relativité
générale dans le vide qui fixe la
géométrie de l'espace temps lorsqu'on
imagine qu'il n'y a aucune densité
d'énergie ou de masse donc par exemple
la métrique de l'espace temps dans un
espace-temps entièrement vide la
métrique de mintzkov ski de la
relativité restreinte obéit à cette
équation mais pas seulement la métrique
d'un trou noir de schwarzschild un trou
noir si ferrique qui est une solution du
vide et bien est également une solution
de cette équation et la métrique de care
qui décrit un trou noir tournant est
elle aussi une solution de cette
équation en fait dès lors que vous êtes
un endroit de l'espace temps qui ne
contient aucune matière où aucune
énergie et bien cette équation
s'applique et localement la métrique va
être une des solution de cette équation
et plus généralement ce que einstein va
écrire c'est que cette grandeur ce temps
ce match elle est égale à thémines eu
ou en tout cas est proportionnel avec
une constante cap à la constante
d'einstein temu étant le temps soeur
énergie impulsion qui décrit le contenu
de l'univers et qui vaut zéro lorsque
l'on se trouve dans le vide